les enfants sont interdits sur la plage
c'est fou non
on reste toujours ensemble rien ne peut
nous séparer
on est bientôt arrivé tu avais dix ans
minutes techniquement ça fait plus de
cinq minutes nancy ont essayé tous de
ralentir un peu
[Musique]
tu te rends compte j'ai trouvé ça sur le
net et pas si secrète que ça cette plage
trop beau il ya des gens qui jettent ça
ça bien de l'hôtel c'est tout rouillé
qu'est-ce qui se passe ils ont trouvé
des affaires de l'hôtel dans le sable
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elle a une maman je sais
pas
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer son corps
s'est décomposé ça prend combien de
temps ça sept ans mais elle vient de
mourir à temps où sont les enfants
et vous avez vu mes enfants d'abord
je suis là
papa pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça
qu'est ce qui nous arrive
ma fille a eu six ans il ya deux
semaines
je sais pas ce qui se passe mais ça va à
toute vitesse tu as compris
il ya un problème sur cette place
bon
bah
par s p sur cette note
les gens qui vont par la ceiba luis
si elle arrive là où elle a peut-être
une chance pourquoi elles avancent plus
pourquoi elles avancent plus tard
attendant postes d'emploi
et ça forcément ce qui se passe ici je
ne fais rien nader regarde qu'est-ce que
ça
message on reste toujours ensemble rien
ne peut nous séparer
c'est un truc qui nous dépasse
oh non on n'est pas ici par hasard
[Musique]